let's now introduce ourselves to the
idea of a differential equation and as
we'll see differential equations are
super useful for modeling and simulating
phenomena and understanding how they
operate but we'll get into that later
for now let's just think about or at
least look at what a differential
equation actually is
so if i were to write so let's here's an
example of differential equation if i
were to write that the second derivative
of y plus 2 times the first derivative
of y
is equal to 3 times y this right over
here is a differential equation another
way we could write it if we said that y
is a function of x we could write this
in function notation we could write the
second derivative of our function with
respect to x
plus two times the first derivative of
our function is equal to three times our
function
or if we wanted to use the the leibniz
notation we could also write we could
also write the second derivative of y
with respect to x
plus two times the first derivative of y
with respect to x is equal to 3 times y
all three of these i guess equations are
really representing the same thing
they're saying okay can i find functions
where the second derivative of the
function plus 2 times the first
derivative of the function is equal to 3
times the function itself so just to be
clear these are all essentially saying
the same thing and you might have just
caught from how i described it that the
solution to a differential equation is a
function or a class of functions it's
not just a value or a set of values so
the solution here
so the solution
to a differential equation
is a
is a function
is a function or a set of functions or a
class of functions it's important to
contrast this relative to a traditional
equation so let me write that down so
traditional equation
i guess i could say maybe i shouldn't
say traditional equation differential
equations have been around for a while
so let me write this as a
maybe an algebraic equation that you're
familiar with
algebraic
an algebraic equation
might look something like and i'll just
write a simple quadratic say
x squared
x squared
plus three x
plus two is equal to zero
the solutions to this algebraic equation
are going to be numbers or a set of
numbers we can solve this is going to be
x
plus 2 times x plus 1 is equal to 0
so x could be equal to negative 2 or
x could be equal to negative 1. the
solutions here are numbers or a set of
or or values or set of values that
satisfy that satisfy the equation here
it's a relationship between a function
and its derivatives and so the solutions
or the solution is going to be a
function or a set of functions now how
let's make that a little bit more
tangible what would a solution to
something like any of these three which
really represent the same thing what
would a solution actually look like and
actually let me move over to the let me
move this over a little bit
move this a little a bit so we can take
a look at what some of these solutions
could look like and let me erase this
little
this little stuff that i have right over
here
so and i'm just going to give you
examples of solutions here we'll verify
that these indeed are solutions for i
guess this is really just one
differential equation represented in
different ways but hopefully appreciate
what a solution to a differential
equation looks like and that there is
often more than one solution or there's
a whole class of functions that could be
a solution
so one solution to this differential
equation and i'll just write it as our
first one so one solution i'll call it y
one and i could even write it as y one
of x to make it explicit that it is a
function of x one solution is y one of x
is equal to e to the negative three x
and i encourage you to pause this video
right now and find the first derivative
of y one and the second derivative of y1
and verify that it does indeed satisfy
this differential equation
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
let's work through this together so
that's y1 so the first derivative of y1
well this is going to be you'll see we
just have to do the chain rule here
derivative of negative 3x with respect
to x is just negative 3 and the
derivative of e to the negative 3x with
respect to negative 3x is just e
to the negative
3x and if we take the second derivative
y of y1 this is equal to the same exact
idea derivative of this is negative 3
times negative 3 is going to be 9
e to the negative
3x
and now we can just substitute these
values into the differential equation or
these expressions into the differential
equation to verify that this is indeed
going to be true for this function so
let's verify that so let me
so we first have
what the second derivative of y so
that's that term right over there so we
have 9
e to the negative
3x
plus
plus
2 times the first derivative
so that's going to be 2 times this right
over here so it's going to be
minus 6. i'll just write plus
negative 6
e to the negative 3x notice i just took
this 2 times the first derivative 2
times the first derivative
is going to be equal to or needs to be
equal to if this indeed does satisfy if
y 1 does does indeed satisfy the
difference the differential equation
this needs to be equal to 3 times y well
3 times y is
3 times e to the negative 3x 3 e to the
negative
3x and let's see if that indeed is true
so
these two
terms right over here 9 e to the
negative 3x essentially minus 6 e to the
negative 3x that's going to be 3e
to the negative 3x which is indeed which
is indeed equal to 3e to the negative 3x
so y1 is indeed a solution to this
differential equation but as we'll see
it is not the only solution to this
differential equation for example for
example
let's say let's say y2 is equal to
e
e to the x
is also a solution to this differential
equation and i encourage you to pause
the video again and verify that it's a
solution
so assuming you've had to go at it so
the first derivative of this this is
pretty straightforward is e to the x
second derivative is one of the profound
things of the exponential function the
second derivative here is also e to the
x and so if i have so the second
derivative let me just do those same
colors
so the second derivative is going to be
e to the x
e to the x plus 2 times e to the x
plus 2 times e to the x is indeed
going to be equal to 3 times e to the x
3 times e to the x this is absolutely
going to be true e to the x plus 2 to
the x is 3 e to the x so y 2 is also a
solution to this differential equation
so that's a start in the next few videos
we'll explore this more we'll start to
see what the solutions look like what
classes of solutions are techniques for
solving them visualizing solutions to
differential equations and a whole
toolkit for for kind of digging in and
deeper